[Music]
[Music]
I went to Freedom Fest in July and
there's nothing like thousands of
libertarians crowded together in the
same hotel that makes me want to drink
people know when they come here it's not
matter whether or not they're going to
have a hangover it's only a matter of
how about how bad is going to be Jason
Burke has a new business in town
treating hangovers it's aptly named
hangover heaven and it's a treatment
that comes to you the morning after a
night of fun
Jason's hangover bus gives customers a
nutrient filled IV to get them hydrated
and feeling good again people come to
Vegas to decompress and have a good time
the one nice thing about Nevada is it's
not a high regulatory state great I feel
like my eyes
those might have been tears of joy
because I could actually get treated for
this agony without going through
insurance or other regulatory hurdles
there were only a few agencies that I
had to speak with which was nice and
people were definitely nervous because
this business didn't fit into anything
and the usual response was you're going
to do what on a what and they said
basically if there's a position on the
bus
especially you as an anesthesiologist
it's okay I want innovation I want great
ideas I want technology
I want that frontier spirit I want to
have a pap smear in the back of the tour
bus preferably with a rock band on board
but with genius ideas like this there's
bound to be some criticism as well
people have very strong opinions and
feelings about hangovers there are some
people that have I guess I'm only going
to call like an Elizabethan view the
thing that anything that's good or
pleasurable should be followed by
something miserable to keep you from
doing that pleasurable thing well people
are going to keep drinking I mean that's
that's their choice and this is really
innovative healthcare I mean this is
innovative individualized health care
that meets a direct need while Jason
does customize each IV based on the
patient and symptoms he generally uses a
combination of vitamins magnesium and
calcium to rehydrate and get the toxins
out of the system the basic treatment
cost 99 dollars but if you think of the
opportunity cost of losing a full day in
Vegas due to a hangover it doesn't seem
so bad the IV medications work extremely
fast they're extremely effective and I
really know how to use them this
treatment seems to be pretty popular and
isn't this what market-based health care
is all about lower costs without
subsidized insurance individualized
treatment demand for a particular good
or service we're only two and a half
months into the business plan of already
about probably 50 percent higher and
revenues than I expected to be at this
point we have probably 40 people already
reserved for this coming weekend you
said you have a rugby team that has
already looked you in advance correct
that's a team that I'd like to party
with them Baker
you